alma y blanca están jugando un juego en
el que tienen que tirar dos dados de
seis lados cada uno y tratar de predecir
los resultados blanca piensa que la
probabilidad de tirar un 1 y un 5 es
mayor la probabilidad de tirar un 1 y un
5 es mayor que la probabilidad de tirar
un 1 o un 5 alma no está de acuerdo ella
piensa que la probabilidad de tirar un 1
o un 5 es mayor con base en el espacio
muestral que se muestra a continuación
quién tiene la razón alma blanca pues no
podemos simplemente mirar el espacio
muestral y ver cuál de estos resultados
satisface cada una de estas situaciones
así que la probabilidad de tirar un 1 y
un 5 la probabilidad de tirar un 1 y un
5 podemos ver en esta cuadrícula que
tenemos un total de 36 resultados
igualmente probables y cuántos de estos
son un 1 y un 5 bueno aquí hay un 1 y un
5 este es un resultado y también tenemos
un 1
5 de este lado aquí hay un 1 y un 5
tenemos 2 resultados igualmente
probables de tirar un 1 y un 5 así que
esto es igual a 1 sobre 18 de
probabilidad de que pase 1 sobre 18
ahora cuál es la probabilidad de tirar
un 1 o un 5 bueno la probabilidad de
tirar un 1 o un 5 probabilidad de tirar
un 15 todo lo que tenemos aquí contiene
un 1
todos estos contienen un 1 y todos estos
contienen un 5
aquí contienen todos estos resultados
contienen un 5 y aquí tenemos más
resultados que contienen un 1
estos también contienen un 1 y estos de
aquí también contienen un 5 estos
resultados contienen un 5 estos son los
resultados que tienen un 1 en el primer
dado estos contienen 5 en el primer dado
estos contienen un 1 en el segundo dado
y estos contienen 5 en el segundo dado
entonces cuántos resultados tenemos aquí
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 y 20 tenemos veinte resultados
de 36 igualmente probables o si
dividimos el numerador y el denominador
entre 4 nos da 5 sobre 95 novenos de los
resultados contienen un 1 o un 5 y 5
novenos claramente es mayor que 1 sobre
18 5 novenos es igual a 10 sobre 18 así
que la probabilidad de obtener un 1 o un
5 es mayor
'alma tiene razón ella piensa que la
probabilidad de obtener un 1 o un 5 es
mayor con base en el espacio muestral
quién tiene la razón alma estuvo bien
que hiciéramos el ejercicio de encontrar
estos subconjuntos en el espacio
muestral que cumplieran con las
condiciones que tenemos aquí pero
también podríamos pensar en eso si no
tuviéramos el espacio muestral
blanca piensa que la probabilidad de
tirar un 1 y un 5 es mayor
bueno tener un 1 y un 5 es mucho más
difícil de obtener que tiran un 1 o un 5
si tiramos un 1 a un 5 eso incluye que
tengamos un 1 y un 2 o un 1 y un 3 o un
5 y un 3 o cualquier otro número junto
con el 1 o el 5 y no solo 1 y 5 bueno
nosotros ya calculamos aquí las
probabilidades pero sin ni siquiera
mirar esta lista lo que alma dice tiene
sentido porque es más fácil tirar un 1 o
un 5 que un 1 y un 5